iran's president-elect said this morning
that the u.s
must lift all sanctions on his country
and he will not
meet with president biden ibrahim raisi
a protege of iran's ruling ayatollah
won an election where more than half the
people did not
vote elizabeth palmer is in iran's
capital where young people are finding
other ways
to express their views it's early
evening
and the gang's all here trying new moves
perfecting old ones and just generally
hanging out
it's often difficult in this
conservative and tightly controlled
society
to know what freedoms the next
generation is really longing for
but there is one place in tehran where
it's all on show
the skate park it's an oasis of freedom
in a country where
so much is forbidden kids who come here
girls and boys have a lot in common with
kids everywhere
how much time do you guys spend on
social media this is simple
24 hours 24 7. just hang with our
mobiles
mobile phones iranians of all ages
just love them they're the gateway to
another
oasis of freedom in this repressive
country the internet
where people can say things they never
could in public
take last week's presidential election
an online campaign
urged citizens to boycott support for
what it called
a murderous regime a reference to the
demonstrators killed by security forces
in 2019
that's what's written on all these hands
don't vote
posted online by iranians from across
the country
and in the end millions didn't thanks in
part to this device
even though many sites and platforms are
blocked in iran
more than half of all eligible voters
didn't cast
a ballot some saw the election as a
farce
there were seven official candidates but
cartoons suggested
that only one the regime's man would be
allowed to win
spaces where people conduct the rules
and be themselves in iran
are rare and all the more precious for
that
out here look this is amazing this is
you're doing what you want you're having
it's a special place this area is free
this place is free for cbs this morning
i'm elizabeth palmer
in tehran